- There’s a nest
right here somewhere.
- Let’s roll.
- I find myself at a time now
when the alligators
went from a time
when they were barely extinct
to just a population explosion.
It’s almost to the point
to where it’s us against them.
There’s a nest
right here somewhere.
Alligator season’s
only for a short time.
The egg-collecting program
is important
if you’re gonna get
the alligator population
under control.
We use helicopters to fly
and find the nest
over the open marsh.
We’ll mark the nest with a GPS,
and then I take those eggs
and bring them to the farm
where we could take the eggs,
hatch some,
use that
as a commercial business,
and return some to the wild.
But even with that,
these alligators
are still thriving.
- Whoa!
- There she is.
- Give me your paddle.
- The egg collection
requires a person like me
to go up to the nest,
and then you’re gonna have
to take the eggs
away from the mother.
And we can’t carry a gun,
so it’s you and mad mama.
- Give me that paddle.
- Wait, wait, wait.
Watch it.
Wait, dad.
He might get in the boat.
Hold on.
Get your box, man.
It’s a standoff,
but I’m not leaving
without my...come on.
- Get back!
- Come on.
Come on.
Come on, girl.
- Watch him, watch him!
- Hold on.
Come on, girl, come on.
Whoa!
Get back!
Come on, girl, get--
Come on.
- Like a bulldog.
- Give us a break!
- Man!
- Come on!
Come on.
- Okay, now we got a break.
All right.
- Watch it! Aah!
Get back! Come on!
Try to get the eggs.
Okay,
you’re gonna have to hurry.
Oh! Watch it, dad.
She came over my paddle!
Wait. Come on, girl.
All right,
let’s get back in the boat.
I don’t wanna
turn my back on her
’cause she’s mean as hell.
All right, let’s go.
- That’s 36 less alligators
in the wild, dad,
to destroy everything.
- Let’s roll.